ever wondered what the innermost desire  of scp-140 or an incomplete chronicle  might be foundation researchers took a  photo of scp-140 while it was at rest  inside of its vault and this was the  result a number of ornately dressed  women look on with approval at an  assortment of human corpses impaled on  stakes said corpses include civilians of  multiple ethnicities soldiers dressed in  the military uniforms of a number of  countries and foundation global occult  coalition and horizon initiative  operatives background buildings are gray  and appear to be made of basalt this is  certainly one wish we can all hope never  comes true